ils ont on laisse les lumières des
grands magasins parisiens pour prendre
la direction de lyon où s'est ouvert
hier soir la traditionnelle fête des
lumières justement la fête des lumières
qui va durer jusqu'à samedi autrefois
c'était une fête religieuse qui sait
laïcisé en quelque sorte au fil des
années et dont la ville de lyon a décidé
de faire un festival qui attire tout de
même chaque année plusieurs millions de
spectateurs reportage didier guyot et
thierry cimolai
c'est une tradition qui si à lyon
perpétue depuis 1852 en hommage à la
vierge marie qui aurait sauvé la ville
de la peste chaque 8 décembre des
lumières illuminent la cité
ne soit purement traditionnelle soit un
petit peu festif soit religieux mais on
a tous une raison de faire mais au fil
des années la tradition s'est transformé
en immense fête populaire
et c'est toute la ville qui est devenu
lumière bâtiment éclairé performance
visuelle et musicale jeux d'ombré de
lumière avec des centaines de milliers
de personnes qui déambulent dans les
rues
les lumières dans la rue l'ambiance les
gens la musique les spectacles de vence
a appelé des terreaux et c'est ici c'est
vraiment pour
convivial parce que c'est sympathique
parce qu'on est bien
la face éclairée
spectacle insolite sur la façade de la
cathédrale saint-jean une odyssée dédié
à la terre et aux animaux un spectacle
en relief lunettes oblige mais les
lyonnais n'oublie pas non plus que de ce
8 décembre est aussi une fête religieuse
alors un flambeau à la main et s'en
iront en pèlerinage à la basilique de
fourvière
voici l'invité des cinq dernières